>>Announcer: Thanks for coming, I’m happy
to introduce David Stephenson today. David
shared with me that there are several Google
links to the book and to his work. The idea
for this book has a pedigree that goes back
Eric Schmidt and Tim O'Reilly and the conversation
they were having soon after the 2008 election.
The topic of this book came up and Eric told
Tim O'Reilly someone should write a book about
this. Soon enough David was doing so. And
that’s one of the sources of this book.
David is principle of Stephenson Strategies,
Medfield enterprise in government web 2.0
consultant firm. He is a leader in data liberation
and the open government movement. He was a
consultant on transparency strategies to the
District of Columbia Office of Chief Technologist.
That was when Vivek Kundra was holding that
post. He was also the co-author of Data Dynamite,
except he was poached ruthlessly by someone
named President Obama to be the nation's first
CIO, and apparently decided to take him up
on that. Stephenson's lectures worldwide on
data liberation, writes great books and also
articles and blog post on data and other issues
including homeland security and environmental
tragedy. Dave, thank you very much for coming
and joining us today.
>>DAVID STEPHENSON: Thank you David, I really
appreciate it. So, today I'm going to give
you an overview on my book, Data Dynamite.
And also try to relate that to Google and
particularly to Google's mission. But before
I get going I have admit a couple of things
about myself. First of all, I was a religion
major in college. While I never had any intentions
of becoming a minister I have become an evangelist.
Only, I'm an evangelist for change. And I
hope that my enthusiasm for this subject comes
across today. Secondly, if you are familiar
with the Myers-Briggs personality test. According
to research about 95% of engineers are classified
in the Myers-Briggs as INTJ's: Introspective,
intuitive, thinking and judging which makes
you the polar opposite of me, ENFP: Extroverted,
intuitive, feeling and perceiving. That can
be one of two things, either we are going
to talk right pass each other or we can find
a synthesis where we benefit from the best
of each other's thinkings. I like to think
that that is what we are going to do today.
The third thing about myself is that I think
of it sometimes as a cosmic joke that I should
be writing a book about data. Because of a
gruesome incident that I will not go into
detail, about a 7th and 8th grade algebra
teacher who didn't know how to deal with people
with ADD left me permanently scared when it
came to dealing with data. So, for the longest
time, as far as I was concerned there was
only one reason to deal with data. And that
was to go over the Red Sox batting averages.
Look what that got us. Eventually I did come
around and became convinced of the value of
data. And when I became convinced of that
value of data, I found it really difficult
to get hold of it. For the longest time that
was very legitimate. It was costly, difficult,
a lot of technological barriers to gathering,
processing, and disseminating data. But as
you and I know, those have all been taken
care of and yet this mind set still remains.
It’s very much, as far as I'm concerned,
like that last scene in Raiders of the Lost
Ark. Where the Ark was boxed up in a crate
and put in a government warehouse. And you
knew that it was never going to be accessed
again. And it seems to me that when you substitute
data warehouse, it’s such a wonderful term.
In its symbolic aspects that, unfortunately,
often stuff gets into the data warehouse and
we never see it again.
But I maintain that time has come to end that
practice and that it is time for data for
the rest of us. The time has come to liberate
data. Liberating data makes it automatically
available for all who need it, when and where
they need it, in forms to use and with freedom
to use as they choose, while at the same time
protecting privacy and security. And I maintain
that this is really crucial for a lot of today’s
challenges. I think that the whole concept
of liberating data is crucial to deal with
some of the issues we are facing today. First
of all, within the corporate workplace, if
you give people real time data for the first
time ever. In the past we have had a situation
where that has been primarily limited to senior
executives and elites in areas like marketing
and things like that due to do the costs of
DI dashboards and other barriers of that sort.
When you start giving people access to real
time data they can really use, you are going
to get better decision making, particularly
if you add in social media tools to be able
to collaboratively analyze and act on that
data. I think you are going to get fundamentally
better decision making because you are going
to get a number of different perspectives
brought to bear on it. Secondly, you are going
to be able to automate a lot of processes
that have been manual in the past. That certainly
has economic benefits to it. Thirdly, one
of the big demands of the republicans in the
US. I did a lecture in Montreal on a related
subject this week with an international audience.
And I was saying to them that this is equally
applicable on worldwide basis. But focusing
just in the US right now, one of the concerns
with the GOP is cutting the cost of government
regulations. There is a tremendous potential
when you have seamless flow of data to cut
the cost of regulatory reporting. And at the
same time, this is somewhat paradoxical. The
experiences in Australia and the Netherlands,
the two places that have really done this
to the greatest extent. They've actually been
capable of improving the quality of regulation.
And that’s because of the fact that for
the first time ever when companies file a
single unified data file that goes to the
central government and then automatically
flows into all of the different agencies,
for the first time ever all those agencies
can survey a given company at the same time.
And equally important, and I think this is
true both within the business sector. I would
argue that banks, probably more than any other
sector of the economy would benefit from this.
Because I don't know about you, but frankly
I don't trust any bank anymore. And the only
way they are going to earn my trust is through
transparency. There is actually a professor
who I finally met in this conference in Montreal
who was saying that, had a system of the sort
I'm talking about been in effect in the mid-2000s
we actually might have totally avoided all
the bank shenanigans and the whole economic
collapse never would have happened. Can you
imagine that? That is rather damning. And
finally, so that you can restore this through
transparency and earn the public trust. And
finally, probably on a most imaginative stand
point, you can also make the public partners
and crowdsource a lot of innovation. Now how
would you actually go about doing this? In
the book I outline a five step process that
starts with making the organization truly
data centric. I mean that almost as much literally
as figuratively. That thinking of, in a very
systemic way, on your date flow coming from
the center of the corporation. No matter where
it is housed but coming from the center and
they flowing through massive feedback loops,
coming back in again, so you have this continuous
flow of data. Secondly, and I can’t emphasize
this enough I’m going to call Google on
this to some extent also. The second step
is tagging and syndicating data. The goal,
I’m convinced that we need to be pursuing
is entering data one time, only one time.
That’s perfectly feasible now, with tagging
of data. Because all I have to do is enter
once and then repot those tags elsewhere and
the date will automatically flow to those
places and the language that I’m particularly
obsessed with right now is XBRL. The eXtensible
Business Reporting Language which from everything
I’ve been able to learn about Google until
now seems that even Google is not using.
There is only a handful literally of companies
worldwide who are using the extensible business
language reporting. Behind the firewall everybody
now is required to us it when they report
to the SCC. But behind the firewall you
have literally five organizations in the whole
world from the cutting edge change that are
realizing all sorts of incredible benefits.
But Google is not one of them. So one of the
things you get is as benefit. When you start
with this and you only enter the data once
is that you get a single version of the truth.
All you have to do, [cough] the data doesn’t
get altered when you enter it into an Excel
Spreadsheet. It retains what one of my friend's
calls its status as a data nugget where the
metadata is attached to that from the tag
and it retains its identity wherever it ends
up being used. the next step is to provide
tools. I was hoping that my friend Gordon
Wattenberg would be here today because this
is a tool that Martin developed before he
joined Google when he was over at IBM called
Many Eyes and its symbolic of a wide range
of tools that.
For those of us who are not left brain and
analytical can really make data come alive.
This was the very first data visualization
that I even did. I had never used any of the
tools before, I had to scrape the data because
it has not been structured from a PDF, upload
the data and then enter it into this particular
visualization tool. And believe me if you
see the original chart, even the most highly
trained statistician would be hard to find
the symbolic or the importance of all this
stuff. And yet when you did that with Many
Eyes it comes to mind right away, now how
did I manage to get to this? I’ve locked
up and I can't seem to get beyond it. Hmm.
Anybody have an idea?
>>Male AUDIENCE #1: Try the escape key.
>>DAVID STEPHENSON: The escape key, of course.
Ok, the next thing is to get workers the data.
It doesn’t help to have all this data available
if you don’t get it to workers. And I’ve
maintained that that means every worker gets
the data that is relevant to his or her specific
needs. In the District of Columbia one of
the things they did was that they actually
got down to the level of the individual worker
or the crews who were filling pot holes In
the past they used to get a list of the pot
holes they were to fill and the order they
were to fill them in. It gave no credit to
these guys who had been working on the streets
of the District of Columbia for years. For
the knowledge that they had accumulated of
what was the logical order to do this in.
So now they get a display of the pot holes
that have to be filled and they get choose
the order on which they have to do it. And
if that means that they find themselves across
the street from Dunkin Doughnuts at 10:15
in the morning, so be it. It's an understanding
of the real world aspect of all this so you
have to get the people the data that they
need. And then finally the last step that
I outline in the book is of actually sharing
your data. I did and extensive thing about
the Netflix price back before Netflix started
to stumble. You may remember that they did
this incredible crowdsourcing trying to improve
their algorithm. And they released millions
and millions animized records of rental patterns
and challenged. I go into a little bit of
detail in the book but I urge you to go to
the web and find the narratives that actually
accompany the entries into this because it
was the most incredible social media mediated
type of process that brought everybody in.
This is another example, Beth Noveck who recently
left the Obama administration as the deputy
CTO before she joined the administration had
done something called "Peer to Patent" that
actually crowdsourced the whole patent review
process. As you may know the patent review
pressed is way behind the times and by opening
that to the publicthey where able to cut
significantly into that back log and actually
improve the quality of the process. So how
does this actually work in real life? I would
like to give you two example from right here.
One of them right here in Cambridge with a
company call Vitality Inc. that makes a really
high tech product called apill bottle cap.
Now this is not your grandmothers pill bottle
cap each one has its own IP Address. Each
one has a low power transmitter in it and
a little LED and each one is programmed for
your particular prescription and the time
at which you are supposed to take it and about
a half an hour before you are supposed to
take . It starts to glow slightly there are
little tinkling sounds to remind you. As soon
as you take the top off a single is sent to
the Vitality servers. At the end of the month
your doctor gets a report on how frequently
took the pill. This is one if the thing where
I don’t know about you but when you go to
see your doctor. Particularly the first time
after you had e new prescription for a maintenance
drug The doctor says, "How frequently have
you been taking it?" "Well, I think I took
it most of the time." Well it turns out in
fact there is a 23 billion dollar a year problem
because about half of the population is on
maintenance drugs. And about of that only
half actually take them on regular basis that
mounts up to 23 billion dollars a year in
excess hospitalizations, unnecessary illnesses,
prescriptions that aren't refills and things
of that sort.
And Vitality Inc. system deals with that in
a very, very clever fashion I should say also.
If you don’t take the pill on time a neighbor
or an adult child gets either a text or a
phone message saying "Dad didn’t take his
pill." And then you get on the phone to dad
and harass him to take that it's an amazing
system. The second one is developed across
the river at Beth Israel Deaconess, Dr. John
Halamka who is a polymath if I ever heard
one. If you haven’t seen it check his
blog my life as a health care CIO. He has
five official titles as well as many others
including, he's not just CIO at the hospital
he is also a ER doctor there, and he points
out that if you are a patient in the ER you
want to make darn sure that has got access
to every line of your record because you
may not be in a position to tell him anything
about it. On the other hand a physician in
the same hospital or billing clerk or somebody
of that sort doesn’t need accessand shouldn’t
have access to the whole record. And so they
designs in a whole series of redundant controls
to make sure that information is available
to those who need it. But only on a need
to know basis and if you can imagine I can't
imagine any more data centric application
that is bothliterally a matter of life or
death and where security and privacy are also
paramount, so it's a great example of that.
So,how can we actually build a data centric
society and what in particular can Google
do to play a role on this? I think that if
your mission as just being perfectly in line
with what I'm talking about and I'd like to
suggest a couple specific steps that I think
you could do and I would be glad to meet with
some of you over lunch to talk about some
other things. First of all you can be a model.
As I mentioned unless I’m sadly mistaken
Google is not using the extensible business
report language global ledger behind the firewall.
So I’m here by throwing down the virtual
gauntlet.
>> AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
>>DAVID STEPHENSON: [laughing] Well hopefully
they’ll see the video.
>>Female Audience #1: can you explain whets
special about that?
>>DAVID STEPHENSON: Sure, let me just finish
and then I'll be glad to do that. Secondly,
provide tools. this happens to be the nonprofit
Gapminder. You all have bought the commercial
rights to it and it's known now as Public
Data Explorer but Martin and his group and
a number of others have developed all sorts
of wonderful data visualization tools within
Google. I am also challenging you to do more
to get those out to the general public so
that they can use them. If you haven’t I
strongly urge you to do at least one visualization
with Public Data Explorers. Anybody ever used
that? It's incredible because you know, it
actually animates the data and it is so compelling
what you can do with that. It's remarkable.
Next thing would be promote data, that was
one of the things that intrigued me the other
day was what if, on the results page, up here
maybe between videos and news if there was
a new line on the results page that said data
and had links to relevant data associated
with the results of your search. I think that
would be absolutely incredible; that’s another
challenge to you.
Now, I happen to be very optimistic about
making this transformation and because of
my belief on the work of Steve Martin. I’m
sorry, I meant to say Steve Jobs and Martin
Luther that makes me optimistic about this.
When you think about it, a friend of mine,
Wendy Jameson is CEO of high tech firm in
Phoenix when she saw the first chapter in
my book she said "You know, what you are talking
about here is really for data the same kind
of thing Martin Luther did for the written
word." And look at those statistic that is
actually amazing, Gutenberg had invented the
movable press,I guess 50 years before Luther
did his work with translating the Bible into
German and then printing it. But it was really
with Luther that the printing press took off.
And I see a direct analogy there, this is
a thing that Wendy pointed out to me. That
Luther got rid of the necessity of relying
on a trained Priesthood, in this case it was
literality a Priesthood of the monkswho
had to translate the bible into vernacular
German. Suddenly he did that so everybody
had direct access to the Bible. And then secondly
instead of having it copied by hand by the
monks it was instead available on a printed
bases. So you have 390 editions published
in the year 1523. Think about that. With it
the small population in general in Europe
and then the even smaller population who were
actually literate, that is an astounding number.
By 1525, three million copies of pamphlets
relating to Luther were in print and equally
interesting, he actually transformed the nature
of scholarship. Up until then the best and
the greatest were these monks who spent almost
their entire day hand copying illuminated
manuscripts And after Luther came along
that was no longer necessary so this same
monks were suddenly able to actually engage
in original scholarship. And my other source
of inspiration is Steve Jobs in this regard.
One of the things, I don’t know if Walter
Isaacson has it in his new biography of Jobs
but there was a very revealed interview that
Terry Gross from Fresh Air did with him in
1996 before he came back to Apple where he
said that "Our goal is to bring a liberal
art perspective and a liberal arts audience
to what has traditionally had been a very
geeky technology and a very geeky audience."
So my final challenge to you and I think that
the Google search interface to me represents
very much the same kind of esthetic as Jobs
accomplished with all of his products. So
my challenge is to keep up the good work in
that regard and to do everything you can to
demystify the collection of data and dissemination
of data. So thank you very much and I'd be
glad to take questions now.
>>Male Audience #2: So one of main challenges
from the Google perspective is you can't give
the user all the data related to a question
they pose. So it has to be narrowed down
a lot, whether you do such a thing as have
people subscribe to a feed of data matching
certain criteria have them do queries grammatically
in some way. With the client side tool to
specify it without programming and there are
various things like this already going on.
They are just not web wide standardize. So
once you get to the vast amount of data the
little that goes into it. The reward for standard
encoding drops a lot because now it's about
the interface. So I think until we see this,
maybe already exists, see enough desire to
match up different things together. For
example you might do queries for all books
matching certain criteria and news about those
authors.
>>David Stephenson: Hm Hmm.
>>Male Audience #2: [inaudible] Such things
start being done
>>David Stephenson: Right.
>>Male Audience #2: or expressed as a desire.
>>DAVID STEPHENSON:I think you are right about
that. One of the things that I did ton include
I this but I had in my talk in Montreal thatgave
me a great deal of optimism about the task
of structuring data and the benefit that could
bring about is what is already happening spontaneously
with Flicker photos, Facebook photos , hashtags
on Twitter. I happen to be user number 262
on Twitter soI’ve been there from day
three with Twitter and I remember distinctly
when hashtags were introduced and I also remember
distinctly nobody telling me a thing about
what they were for and I also remember within
probably two days or so just intuitively figuring
in it out in my own what it was. And I watched
with great interest; my other fields is home
land security and particular use of social
media in disasters and terrorism attacks.
I’ve watched with a great deal of interest
the increasing sophistication of the use of
hashtags when it comes to things like the
Arab spring and so I think that there is an
inherent understanding. I think the bottom
line on this is people are doing it not just
to be altruistic but because they realize
the benefit to themselves of tagging that
information. So it doesn’t seem to me to
be a big leap of faith to go from tagging
photos to tagging original data. And in of
the things I have sort of taken on as my particular
niche and I will get to the question about
XBRL in just a minute that I have taken as
my own particular niche in that field is that
I think what we need to do. Another very legitimate
concern that people have is the sheer volume
of data within any large organization and
how the hell are you possibly going to get
a handle on all of that? And I maintain that
the way to do that is to actually give the
person who has to physically enter that data
the first time, give them ownership of that
data. You know, in reality you already have
ownership of that data in the negative standpoint,
if something goes wrong, if it's entered incorrectly
the full wrath of Khan will descend upon you.
You’ll be appropriately punished. But I’m
talking about it in a more positive sense
of giving people ownership for the data and
I’m convinced that we can create perhaps
through a collaborative effort of government
and industry a whole bunch of tools that will
demystify taggingand make it feasible for
people without a great deal of expertise to
accurately, people can tag data right now,
but if you can't do it accurately, what is
the value? But I’m enough of an optimist
to think it would be possible to do that.
Let me get to the question about XBRL. Its
the acronym stand for eXtensible Business
Reporting Language and Google and every other
publically trading company now is required
by the SCC to report to them using XBRL
and what they have done its been captured
by the accountants. I love accountants they
are some of my best friends the Maryland Association
of CPAs thinks I’m a rock star because of
this book. But accountants are paid to be
diligent and orderly and methodical. They
are not played to be visionaries. So unfortunately
in the public mind, in the corporate mind
XBRL has been equated almost exclusively and
this a big theme of this conference in Montreal,
with regulatory compliancy which is the kiss
of death. If there is a tool that has to be
used to comply with regulation nobody in their
right mind is going to use it otherwise. Now,
here is the cool thing. There is a subset
which is the one that I showed that slide
of called XBRLGL, Global Ledger which uses
all of the term in general ledger accounting.
Which are all the standard business terms
is anyone in the audience from the business
side of stuff. Well that's good because anyone
of us could actually understand any one of
those tags. There is no mystery at all. They
are basically business accounting terms. And
Wacoal, a Japanese lingerie firm, Fujitsu
and Hitachi are the only films I know of and
then there is this nonprofit, the Maryland
Association of CPAs Has also just very recently
done it and they just singing the praises
of the XBPRGL because then, what is so cool
about it, because it uses the subset of the
tags of XPRL in general, your regulatory compliances
that companies all over the place bitch about,
and for good reasons, It really is complicated
and costly to comply with regulatory requirements.
The actual completion of your regulation documents
becomes almost automatic, It becomes basically
part of doing business. A friend of mine,
David Siegel wrote a book called Pull actually
argued in there, I hate to say it to my accounting
friend, the role of accountants might almost
vanish in 100 years or so because of this.
So, yes.
>>Male AUDIENCE #3: So the advantage if you
represent everything is this language is that
there is accounting standards and compliance
cut for free. But that’s basically the
work up front by representing everything in
this language, why are, this four examples
you gave us, why are they all using this?
>>DAVID STEPHENSON: Because they also realizing
of sort of day in and day out economic advantages
as a result of this. Wacoal has been able
to go. They were able to take 34 legacy
accounting systems and unify them without
going back and reworking the code. They were
able to standardize everything on Oracle all
they had to do is to add. The truth is that
I wish I could remember off the top of my
head in this specific savings but they really
have been astounding. The truly incredible
thing as far as I'm concerned is that one
the XBRL.org website the case study that they
show is this one from Wacoal from seven years
ago. And I think the problem has been, it
has nothing to do with the merits XPRLGL.
It's become associated with regulatory compliance
so people are totally ignoring the other side.
I urge you being enlightened people to check
it out and I do write about it in the book.
>>Male AUDIENCE #4: It seems to me the similar
benefit going from paper ledgers to computerized
ledgers. You have a medium that communicate
between systems and of course it could be
a huge improvement. But this standard suggests
from the name that it's about money. Most
the data we have is not about money. I don't
just mean Google, but the world, is it actually
adaptable?
>>DAVID STEPHENSON: It adapts to other types
of information as well. Yeah, exactly. Any
other questions? Well, thank you so much.
I really appreciate the opportunity.
[applause]